Como muchos de los que están aquí, estoy tratando de contribuir
a un renacimiento en África.
La cuestión de la transformación en África
es en realidad una cuestión de liderazgo.
África sólo puede ser transformada por líderes bien informados.
Y yo sostengo que la manera en que
educamos a nuestros líderes es fundamental
para progresar en este continente.
Me gustaría contarles algunas historias que explican mi punto de vista.
Ayer, todos oímos lo importante que son las historias.
Una americana amiga mía, este año, hizo un voluntariado como enfermera en Ghana.
Y en un lapso de tres meses, llegó a una conclusión
sobre el estado del liderazgo en África
que a mí me ha costado una década alcanzar.
En dos ocasiones estuvo involucrada en operaciones
en las que se fue la electricidad en el hospital.
Los generadores de emergencia no encendieron,
no había ninguna linterna, ningún farol, ninguna vela.
Completamente oscuro.
El paciente abierto, dos veces.
La primera vez fue una cesárea.
Afortunadamente, el bebé estaba fuera; la madre y el niño sobrevivieron.
La segunda vez fue un procedimiento que involucraba anestesia local.
El efecto de la anestesia se acaba y el paciente empieza a sentir dolor.
Llora. Grita. Reza.
Todo está completamente oscuro. No hay ni una vela, ni una linterna.
Y ese hospital podía haber comprado linternas.
Podrían haber comprado esas cosas, pero no lo hicieron.
Y esto pasó dos veces.
En otra ocasión, vio horrorizada como las enfermeras veían morir un paciente
porque éstas habían rechazado darle el oxígeno que tenían.
Así que, tres meses después,
justo antes de que regresara o a los Estados Unidos,
las enfermeras en Accra hicieron una huelga.
Y su recomendación fue
aprovecha para correr a todas, empiecen todo de nuevo.
Empiecen de nuevo.
Bien, ¿Qué tiene esto que ver con el liderazgo?
Verán, los errores del Ministerio de Salud,
los administradores del hospital, los doctores, las enfermeras;
están entre el 5 por ciento de la población
que recibió educación más allá de la secundaria.
Ellos son la élite. Ellos son nuestros líderes.
Sus decisiones, sus acciones importan.
Y cuando ellos fallan, toda la nación sufre.
Así que cuando hablo de liderazgo,
no estoy hablando sólo de líderes políticos.
Todos hemos oído mucho sobre eso.
Estoy hablando de la élite.
Aquellos que han sido educados.
Y cuyo trabajo es ser los guardianes de su sociedad.
Los abogados, jueces, policías, doctores,
ingenieros, funcionarios;
esos son los líderes.
Y necesitamos educarlos adecuadamente.
Bien, mi primera y memorable experiencia con el liderazgo en Ghana
ocurrió cuando tenía 16 años.
Acababa de pasar un golpe de estado militar,
y la milicia estaba presente en nuestra sociedad.
Eran una presencia que invadía todo.
Un día voy al aeropuerto a buscar a mi padre,
y conforme subo por una pendiente de pasto desde el estacionamiento
hasta el edificio terminal,
me paran dos soldados que llevan rifles AK-47.
Y me piden que me una a un grupo de gente
que estaba marchando arriba y abajo.
¿Por qué? Porque el camino que había tomado estaba considerado zona prohibida.
No había ninguna señal que así lo indicara.
Yo tenía 16 años, y me preocupaba mucho
lo que mis compañeros de escuela pudieran pensar
si me veían corriendo hacia arriba y abajo de la colina.
Me preocupaba especialmente lo que pensarían las chicas.
Así que empecé a discutir con esos hombres.
Yo era algo imprudente, pueden imaginarse, tenía 16 años.
Tuve suerte.
Un piloto aviador de Ghana Airways tuvo el mismo problema.
Y debido a su uniforme hablaron con él de manera diferente,
y le explicaron que simplemente estaban cumpliendo órdenes.
Así que el piloto saca su radio, habla con el jefe de los militares
y nos libera a todos.
¿Qué lecciones se pueden obtener de una experiencia como esta?
Bastantes, según mi punto de vista.
El liderazgo importa. Esos tipos estaban siguiendo
las órdenes de un oficial superior.
Aprendí algo sobre el valor.
Era importante no mirar esas armas.
Y también aprendí que puede ser útil pensar en chicas.
(Risas)
Unos años después de este acontecimiento, salí de Ghana con una beca
para ir a la universidad al Swarthmore College.
Fue un respiro de aire fresco.
En la facultad no querían que nosotros memorizáramos información
y que la repitiéramos, tal como hacía en Ghana.
Querían que pensáramos de forma crítica.
Querían que fuéramos analíticos.
Querían que nos preocupáramos por los problemas sociales.
En mis clases de economía obtuve buenas calificaciones
por mi entendimiento de la economía básica.
Pero aprendí algo más profundo que eso,
y es que los líderes, los que manejaban la economía de Ghana,
estaban tomando malas decisiones;
que habían llevado nuestra economía hacia el borde del colapso.
Así que allí estaba esta lección de nuevo, el liderazgo importa.
Importa muchísimo.
Pero yo no entendía del todo la transformación que me había ocurrido en Swarthmore.
Solo fue un asomo de lo que después entendería.
Pero no me di realmente cuenta hasta que salí al mercado laboral,
y fui a trabajar a Microsoft Corporation.
Me convertí en parte de un equipo; un equipo que pensaba y aprendía
cuyo trabajo era diseñar e implementar nuevo software
que tuviera valor para el mundo.
Y fue genial ser parte de ese equipo.
Fue genial.
Y entonces me di cuenta de lo que me había pasado en Swarthmore,
esta transformación...
la habilidad para enfrentar problemas, problemas complejos,
y diseñar soluciones a esos problemas.
La habilidad de crear es la experiencia de crecimiento personal mas grande
que le puede ocurrir a alguien.
Y yo era parte de eso.
Mientras estuve en Microsoft las ventas anuales de la compañía
crecieron más que el PIB de la República de Ghana.
Y de hecho, continúan creciendo.
La brecha se ha ampliado desde que dejé la compañía.
Ya he hablado sobre una de las razones por las que esto ha ocurrido.
Y hay más; la gente, su dedicación al trabajo,
persistente, creativa, consciente de sus capacidades.
Y también algunos factores externos:
libre mercado, estado de derecho, infraestructura.
Estas cosas que provienen de las instituciones
manejadas por aquellos a los que yo llamo líderes.
Y esos líderes no nacieron espontáneamente.
Alguien los capacitó para hacer el trabajo que hacen.
Mientras yo estaba en Microsoft, pasó algo gracioso,
me convertí en padre.
Y por primera vez África me importó más que nunca.
Porque me di cuenta de que el estado del continente africano
sería relevante para mis hijos y sus hijos.
Que el estado del mundo, el estado del mundo,
depende de lo que esté pasando en África,
respecto a lo que mis hijos concierne.
Y en ese momento en que yo estaba atravesando
lo que yo llamo mi "crisis de la primera mitad de mi vida."
África era un caos.
Somalia se había tornado una anarquía.
Ruanda estaba agonizando de una guerra genocida.
Y me parecía que esa era una dirección incorrecta,
y debía volver y ayudar.
No podía seguir en Seattle y criar mis hijos
en un barrio de clase media-alta y sentirme bien por eso.
Este no era el mundo en que quería que mis hijos crecieran.
Así que decidí involucrarme, y lo primero que hice
fue volver a Ghana y hablar con mucha gente
para tratar de entender cuáles eran los verdaderos problemas.
Y tres cosas se repetían para cada problema:
corrupción, instituciones débiles
y la gente que las manejaba: los líderes.
Yo estaba algo asustado
porque cuando ves esos tres problemas,
parecen realmente difíciles de manejar.
Alguien podría decir: "Ni siquiera lo intentes."
Pero, en mi caso, me pregunté,
"¿De dónde están llegando esos líderes?
¿Que pasa con Ghana que produce líderes
que son poco éticos o que no pueden resolver problemas?"
Así que fui a ver qué pasaba en nuestro sistema educativo.
Y era la misma historia; aprendiendo mediante repetición,
desde la primaria hasta los posgrados.
Muy poco énfasis en la ética.
Y en promedio, el típico graduado
de una universidad en Ghana tiene un sentido más fuerte
de la autoridad que de la responsabilidad.
Esto está mal.
Así que decidí comprometerme en este problema en particular.
Porque me parece que cada sociedad, toda sociedad,
debe determinar cómo formar a sus líderes.
Y en Ghana no se estaba prestando suficiente atención.
Y esto sucede a lo largo del África sub-sahariana.
Así que esto es lo que estoy haciendo ahora.
Estoy tratando de llevar mi experiencia de Swarthmore a África.
Ojalá hubiera universidades humanistas en cada país africano.
Creo que eso implicaría una enorme diferencia.
Y lo que la Universidad Ashesi está tratando de hacer
es educar una nueva generación de líderes éticos y emprendedores.
Estamos tratando de educar líderes de una integridad excepcional,
que tengan la habilidad de enfrentar problemas complejos,
hacer las preguntas correctas y llegar a soluciones factibles.
Debo admitir que hay momentos en que parece ser una "Misión imposible."
Pero debemos creer que estos chicos son inteligentes.
Que si los involucramos en su educación,
si les dejamos discutir los problemas reales que enfrentan,
que toda la sociedad enfrenta,
y si les damos herramientas para conectarlos con el mundo real,
la magia ocurrirá.
A un mes de iniciar este proyecto, cuando apenas iniciamos clases.
Apenas un mes en él, llego a mi oficina,
y recibo este correo de uno de nuestros alumnos.
Y decía, simplemente, "Estoy Pensando."
Y cerraba con un: "Gracias."
Es una afirmación sencilla.
Pero estuve a punto de llorar
porque entendí lo que le estaba pasando a este joven.
Y es maravilloso ser parte del
crecimiento de la gente de este modo.
Estoy Pensando.
Este año lanzamos un reto a nuestros alumnos
el de diseñar un código de honor por si mismos.
Hay un gran debate en estos momento en el campus,
sobre aquello que debe establecerse en un código de honor,
y si acaso debe, cómo habría que escribirlo.
Uno de los estudiantes hizo una pregunta que me conmovió.
¿Cómo creamos a la sociedad perfecta?
Su entendimiento de que un código de honor diseñado por ellos
constituye un paso hacia la perfección es increíble.
No podemos alcanzar la perfección.
Pero si nos encaminamos a ella, podemos alcanzar la excelencia.
No se que terminarán haciendo.
No se si decidirán seguir este código de honor.
Pero las conversaciones que tienen en estos momentos,
acerca de lo que una buena sociedad debería ser,
lo que su sociedad excelente debe parecer,
es realmente bueno.
¿Se me acaba el tiempo? Bien.
Quiero dejar esta diapositiva
porque es importante lo que pensemos acerca de ella.
Estoy muy entusiasmado por el hecho
de que todos los alumnos de la Universidad Ashesi harán servicio comunitario antes de graduarse.
Esto ha sido una experiencia transformadora para muchos de ellos.
Estos futuros líderes empiezan a entender
el verdadero sentido del liderazgo.
El verdadero privilegio del liderazgo,
que es, después de todo, servir a la humanidad.
Y estoy aún más entusiasmado por el hecho de que el año pasado
nuestros alumnos eligieron a una mujer
para ser la Presidenta del Gobierno Estudiantil.
Es la primera vez en la historia de Ghana
que una mujer es elegida Presidenta del Gobierno Estudiantil
en una universidad.
Esto dice mucho de ella.
Y dice mucho también de la cultura que se está formando en el campus.
Dice mucho de los compañeros que la eligieron.
Ganó con el 75 por ciento de los votos.
Y eso me da mucha esperanza.
Resulta que el África corporativo (del Oeste)
también aprecia lo que pasa con nuestros alumnos.
Hemos graduado dos generaciones al día de hoy.
Y cada uno de ellos tiene trabajo.
Y estamos recibiendo reportes fantásticos
de las empresas de Ghana y del África del Oeste.
Y lo que más les ha impresionado ha sido la ética de trabajo.
La pasión por lo que hacen.
La persistencia, su habilidad para manejar la ambigüedad,
su habilidad para enfrentar problemas que nunca habían visto.
Esto es bueno, saben,
durante los pasados cinco años ha habido ocasiones
en que sentía que esto era "Misión Imposible."
Y es maravilloso ver estos destellos
de la promesa de lo que puede pasar si educamos bien a nuestros niños.
Creo que los líderes actuales y futuros de África
tienen una oportunidad increíble
para conducir al continente a un mayor renacimiento.
Es una oportunidad increíble.
No hay muchas oportunidades como ésta en el mundo.
Creo que África ha alcanzado un punto de inflexión
con la marcha de la democracia y la libertad de mercado a lo largo del continente.
Hemos alcanzado un momento del que puede surgir
una gran sociedad en solo una generación.
Eso dependerá del liderazgo inspirador.
Y yo afirmo que la manera en que eduquemos a nuestros líderes
hará toda la diferencia.
Gracias y que Dios los bendiga.
(Aplausos)